(rap ringtone music plays)
[Interview participant] It's
a hoe right here, hold on.
Talk to me.
[Woman On Phone] Hey, are you done yet?
[Interview Participant] I'm
going to be back in a minute.
I told you that already.
[Woman On Phone] No you
didn't. I just got off work.
How you gonna tell me that?
[Interview Participant] Gone ahead.
- [Interviewer] All right Laid.
Laid, oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Laid] From Chicago,
moved out here in '86.
Moved to Fig,
got introduced to this pimping,
you know, at a young age.
Fig is the hoe stroll, you know.
Grandma was a hoe, you know what I mean.
My granddaddy was a pimp.
Shit, my older brother was a pimp.
I grew up into it.
So it's like, I had my first
hoe, you know, on the real.
I didn't even know, she ain't even know
she was hoeing for me.
It just sort of happened, you know.
I told her, you know what I
mean, you're doing it for free
go out there, you know, get money for it,
you know what I mean, we got
to eat, you know, straight up.
- [Interviewer] And you were how old?
- [Laid] 13, you know what I mean.
I was 13.
Yeah. About 13, so you know.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- [Laid] My childhood?
I had to learn, I learned
fast, you know what I mean?
I learned fast, so I had
a rough, I was beaten
you know what I mean?
Grew up around drugs.
Grew up around hoes and
pimps, all that, you know?
So I learned how to, you know,
I guess finesse and
talk to women, you know.
I became somewhat of a
slick talker, you know,
you know a Casanova, what they would say.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] There's different
styles of pimping, you're-
- [Laid] Yeah you got gorilla bimp,
you got finessing, and you got sweet mac.
I'm more finesse sweet mac pimp.
You feel what I'm saying,
I don't, I'm not really
I don't really dig the gorilla tactics.
- [Interviewer] Who showed you
the game when you were young?
You had somebody in the family?
- [Laid] I ain't gonna lie,
when I first did it, like I
said, I had a younger broad.
When I was young, 13.
I introduced her to it.
She was my girl at first,
you know, I just, she
I guess she was already, you know.
- [Interviewer] A lot of the
guys learned it through their
first girl.
- [Laid] Yeah you learn it
through a woman.
- [Interviewer] That's very common.
- [Laid] They teach you,
that's what I'm saying.
And basically like, she
was already, you know
trained to go.
So she basically laced me with the game
and I took off from right there, you know,
and as we went on as I became
good at it and you know,
it stuck.
And once you get a taste of pimping
you know, it's addictive,
it's very addictive.
You know, it's all on an bitch.
You know, you don't really do nothing.
You know, you rest and dress,
you know, you send you a hoe.
- [Interviewer] What's
the key personality trait
that you need to do this?
- [Laid] Basically you got
to just be hard on the whole.
You can't really have, if you
have, if you have any type
of heart, anything, and
they're going to eat you alive.
- [Interviewer] It's all about the money.
- [Laid] It's all about the money.
And they get nothing.
You get it all.
You know what I mean?
You basically are their
manager, you're their bank.
You're their, everything, you feel me.
They trust you with the, you know.
- [Interviewer] They bring
you a hundred percent
of the money.
- [Laid] Yes.
- [Interviewer] And you give them?
- [Laid] I give them security, you know.
I make sure they eat.
Make sure they have
anything that they need.
- [Interviewer] Clothes.
I provide everything that they need,
you feel what I'm saying.
- [Interviewer] When you say security,
how do you actually do that?
- Basically, you know,
just cater to their needs,
you know what I mean?
If they need somebody
to talk to, you gotta
when you a pimp, you gotta be their lover.
You gotta be their, you know,
you gotta be their mentor.
You gotta be their best friend,
you gotta be their, their role model,
you gotta be their everything.
You gotta be their rock,
you feel what I'm saying?
You gotta be their everything.
You gotta think for them,
you feel what I'm saying?
They can't think, you
feel what I'm saying.
They don't have to think.
You don't want them to think.
You gotta think for them,
you feel what I'm saying?
So it's was basically like,
you just, you gotta know,
you know what I mean?
When you do this, it can't be
it gotta be in you, you
know what I'm saying?
It can't be, you can't
just wake up and do this.
This ain't for everybody.
This lifestyle right here,
everybody can say, they
they do this, but you can't do this
unless you are really
about this, you know.
Pimping is a lifestyle, man.
It's a way of life, you know.
It's beautiful, you know what I mean.
It's beautiful.
I love it.
I ain't gonna lie to you.
- [Interviewer] How many girls you got?
- [Laid] In 3 deep, no sleep.
10 toes to the concrete, you know.
- [Interviewer] And your girls work Fig?
- [Laid] Sapota, Fig, I mean
I go back and forth sometimes to the Bay,
you know what I mean?
I be everywhere man.
I get it in. You know.
- [Interviewer] If one of
your girls gets in trouble
with one of the Johns?
- [Laid] She know what to do.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
does she have her phone on
so you can hear what's going on,
or did she call you or was she do?
- [Laid] Yeah she's going to call me,
when she knows to call me.
That's when she, you know what I mean.
But you know, I'll bail her out.
It's a procedure.
She knows not to say anything, you know,
it's a procedure, you know.
Everything will be yummy.
She knows what to do and what not to do.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. You
have sex with your girls?
- [Laid] They got to earn that, you know.
My dick ain't for free.
It's a fee for fucking with me.
You know, hell nah, you know.
- [Interviewer] You been in love before?
- [Laid] Love is for the weak.
Love is for the weak,
you know what I mean.
I have before, everybody has
once upon a time been in love, but
I don't, you know it's been
so long where I don't even
dwell on it, you feel me.
I just, I focused on this pimping, man.
I'm trying to, I'm trying to get it.
I'm trying to pull an Escalade
out of a bitch sweaty ass, man.
That's just what it is.
- [Interviewer] And how
do you handle a girl
if she gets out of line or starts?
- [Laid] Oh if she get
out of line, you know.
Hey, she could beat her feet.
You know, that's how it is.
If they got out of line, you
know, it's different ways,
you know what I mean.
There's different ways to punish them.
You take all they shit, you know.
You can make them get
outside, ass hole naked
standing in the corner.
You feel what I'm saying?
Different variants a little,
you know what I mean.
Just shit like that, you know.
Yeah, you know.
I'll make them put them
on time out, you know
different little stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. The
game has changed a lot.
- [Laid] The game has changed a lot, man.
It's a lot of suckers in the game.
It's a lot of people, you
know, tainting the game,
you feel what I'm saying.
There's not a lot of thoroughbred pimps
out here in this game
anymore, you know what I mean.
So it's kind of hard.
You got to, you know, weed out
the, the fake and the frauds.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do you have a gang past?
- [Laid] Hmm?
- [Interviewer] Were you
in a gang before this?
Or are you currently?
- [Laid] No, I'm all pimping
man. I'm all pimping.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Sometimes they overlap them.
- [Laid] Yeah. Sometimes they do.
- [Interviewer] And
sometimes they're your girls
doing things other than
just sex for money.
Is there, is there some kind of like-
- [Laid] My girls already know
they ain't doing nothing for free.
- [Interviewer] No. But like, you know
sometimes they'll relieve
a trick of his jewelry.
- [Laid] Oh yeah most definitely.
If the opportunity sees
fit, yeah, you know.
It's times where they do
it, but I prefer not to
because I want to keep the
business going, you know.
It's a business, you know,
you don't want to, you know what I mean.
Shit where you stay, you
know, burn your bridges.
But you know, it happens.
It happens.
You have different, you know,
situations where it occurs
but for the most, for, you know.
- [Interviewer] So what
do you look for in a girl?
What kind of personality traits?
- [Laid] She gotta be a good
hoe down, just thoroughbred
hoe and some more, you know what I mean.
Just she, just got to
just be just a nasty,
just go get it hoe, you know.
Just don't care.
Just all she want to do is please me,
you feel what I'm saying.
Just go get the money and
bring it back to daddy,
you know what I mean.
That's just it, that's what I look for.
I look for complete submission,
you know what I mean?
Complete submission.
You know, no questions asked.
No, no lip, you know,
straight up so he can get it.
- [Interviewer] Have you had
girls that just aren't cut out
for this kind of work?
- [Laid] Yeah. You had
those, you had those.
Those the ones you don't want
because those are the ones
that get you, you know
pimping and pandering cases.
So you don't really want to
force anybody to do anything,
you know what I mean.
You present it to them
and try to see, cause
you, know what I mean,
basically turn them out.
If they don't want to do
it, you don't force anything
on nobody, I don't, you know what I mean.
I can try to convince you
and planting a seed, you know
and see if it flourishes.
But if it doesn't
manifests that's, you know.
- [Interviewer] You been arrested before?
- [Laid] Yeah I've been arrested before.
I've been arrested,
assault stuff like that.
Got two pimping and pandering cases.
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah?
- [Laid] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So do
you think that the reason
that these girls will be
interested in a relationship
like the one, the life
that they have, which is,
you know, you think you're
thinking of guys who abused them
or disrespect them, or
just use them basically.
And then working with a pimp
who kind of takes advantage
of their, you know, takes their money,
sometimes treats them badly.
It's a duplicate almost of their childhood
relationship they may have
had with their father, right?
- [Laid] Yeah.
They're missing, I
guess they missing that.
It probably does, you know.
I'm not, I don't really, you know,
I just look at like this, I
just, I'm good at what I do,
you understand me.
So I just try to be,
the best.
I'm gonna say this,
the best, the best pimp or
or the best dad or the best
dad I know because I'm dad.
I mean, that's what
they call me, you know.
I'm dad, you know what I mean.
So I'm the best dad POS I
know, you feel I'm saying.
My hoes love me, know what I'm saying.
Love me.
They cheer, they cater to me.
They, they worship me,
man, you know what I mean.
I'm a God, you know what I mean.
- [Interviewer] What if
the roles were flipped
and you were doing, you
were having sex for money
and the girl was keeping all your money.
Would you ever go for that?
- [Laid] No, I couldn't go for that.
- [Interviewer] But you expect
the girls to do that for you?
- [Laid] Hey, it's the game.
It's the game.
You can't knock the game, man.
It's going to always be.
It goes back to biblical days, man.
You know, this game ain't
going to never cease to
be here man.
Pimping and hoeing is the best
thing going, believe that,
you know, it'll never
change. Very profitable.
You know, it's profitable, man.
There's money in this, man.
You know, it's a lifestyle.
Like I say, everybody can't do this.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- [Laid] 38.
- [Interviewer] 38. So
you been doing it a while.
- [Laid] Been doing it awhile.
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest thing you've seen
in your years of doing this?
- [Laid] Yeah.
[Interviewer] You've seen
some crazy stuff I'm sure.
- [Laid] Yeah I seen a hoe slice her pimp,
you know what I mean.
Seen her slice his ear
off, you know what I mean.
For fucking with another
broad, you know what I mean.
On the blade, you know what I mean.
So, I seen that before.
That was outrageous.
He, she was totally out of
pocket, you know, but you know
that's his pimping and macing.
Mine's is intact, man.
So long as my P's is intact, I'm good.
You know, it's all in about your P's man.
- [Interviewer] It's a dog eat
dog subculture here isn't it?
- [Laid] Exactly.
- [Interviewer] Everybody's
looking out for themselves.
The girls, the guys, the tricks, the-
- [Laid] Exactly. But I'm gonna
tell you one thing though.
As long as you can see, it's
about your game too man.
As long as you can implant, you know
that picture in their
head, you know what I mean.
And you can, you can
implant that, that picture
that beautiful, you know what I'm saying.
You know, whatever reality or
fantasy that they may want,
you know what I mean.
As long as you can fulfill that,
whatever dream that they
want, whatever she, you gotta
you gotta basically
pinpoint whatever they want.
Whatever fantasy that they
want and you just play on it,
you know what I mean.
You exploit it, you feel what I'm saying.
- [Interviewer] It's kinda
like mind control, right?
- [Laid] Exactly, you feel what I saying.
Master manipulation, basically,
you know what I mean.
So, yeah, you know what I mean.
It is what it is.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your years doing this?
- [Laid] To be observant,
you know what I mean.
To be observant and also
basically to humble yourself more,
you know what I mean, pay
attention to everything.
Everything.
Because the smallest thing may count.
You feel what I'm saying?
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Is there a quota
for your girls every night?
- [Laid] Yeah. I need 1200
out of each girl every night,
you know what I mean.
At least 1200. On a bad night, at least 8,
But I need at least 12.
- [Interviewer] They don't
come back until they get it.
- [Laid] No they can't come
back until, yeah, on the real.
I need at least, at the
least, if it's bad I want 8.
You going to get out there and get it.
We got a quota to do,
you know what I mean.
It's a quota to keep,
You understand that. It's a
quota, this is a business.
It shouldn't be no problem
for my girls to get 1200,
you know what I mean, real talk.
Especially with the places I take them to,
you feel what I'm saying.
- [Laid] Where are you
at? Like casinos, and-
- [Laid] Some of them have,
you know, do internet, you know
stuff like that.
Most of them do like a lot
of their dates like that,
but I'll take them Sapota.
- [Interviewer] So do you get
along with the other pimps?
- [Laid] Yeah, you know what I mean.
Yeah, you know what I
mean, I'm a pimp man.
I'm a mac, I don't do all that, you know.
You know what I mean.
- [Interviewer] You guys all like-
- [Laid] Yeah, you know, we
pimps, we're players man.
You know what I mean?
All that.
We ain't got time for all of
that, it's to the bag man.
We ain't got time for all
that, you know, frivolous
you know, we will get ugly
though, you know what I mean.
Don't get it twisted.
It will get ugly though
if, you know what I mean.
But it's cool, man, you know what I mean.
You just get to the, you know what I mean.
Just get to the bag, man.
That's your, you dig?
You feel me?
- [Interviewer] Mhmm. You have kids?
- [Laid] I got a 16 year old son, man.
Stinking ass, fat, nasty, bitch.
Faggot maggot bitch, you know what I mean.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are you raising him?
- [Laid] Nah, nah, he with
her, he with her, man.
- [Interviewer] So your,
your girls at work where?
- [Laid] You said what?
- [Interviewer] Yeah. You
work the internet, you work-
- [Laid] They work the internet, yeah.
They work the internet, back
page, all stuff like that.
What's that?
- [Interviewer] Only fans.
- [Laid] Yeah only fans.
Only fans, you know they
can do stuff on TikToK now.
Yeah.
You can do certain little stuff on TikToK.
You know, you can't actually,
you know what I mean.
You can do certain little
stuff on TikTok though.
- [Interviewer] And they're
on the street as well.
- [Laid] Yeah. At nighttime
though, at nighttime.
In the daytime they don't really,
in the daytime they do
like the internet stuff
and all like that.
They do a lot of webcam
shows and stuff like that.
Fetishes and everything like that.
You get a lot of freaky motherfuckers
that like to do web cam. I'm serious, bro.
That's a lot of money
in that role playing and
dressing up, interaction like
that, you know what I mean.
Little shows and shit.
It's all type of little
shit, you know what I mean.
- [Interviewer] And if a girl wants out,
can she get out?
[Laid Sighs Deeply]
- [Laid] You know what I mean, shit.
They going to find a way to
get out, you know what I mean.
If they're going to get out,
I'm not going to force it.
Like I said, you know,
that doesn't really, you
feel what I'm saying.
I don't force nobody to do nothing, man.
She gonna do what the fuck she want to do,
you know what I mean.
9 times out of 10 when they
dealing with me, you know
I'm with some pimping
man, you know what I mean.
Just keeping it clean.
You ain't going to be fucking with me
if you not even knowing,
you know what I mean.
I'm letting that lean on off the dribble,
that's all I'm about.
I ain't with none of that Square shit.
I mean real talk bro,
you know what I mean.
Just keeping it clean with you, you know.
- [Interviewer] All right Laid.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
I wish you the best of
luck out there, man.
Thank you very much.
- [Laid] Thank you, peace.